Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Three: Danish literature from the 1960s to today.
The middle of the 1960s was characterised by a development in Danish literature that went in many new directions, with authors such as Suzanne Brøgger, born 1944.
While Suzanne Brøgger largely wrote novels about women's liberation, a number of other authors were inspired by rock music, youth rebellion and popular culture.
Another striking poet was Inger Christensen, who lived from 1935 to 2009.
Her poem "Sommerfugledalen", "Butterfly Valley", from 1991, is regarded as one of the great works in recent Danish literature.
Inger Christensen's works have been translated into many languages.
She was mentioned several times as a strong candidate for the Nobel Prize in Literature.
Naja Marie Aidt, born 1963, also began her writing as a poet, but has since also written novels and short stories.
Her best-known work is Har døden taget noget fra dig, så giv det tilbage.
Carls bog, "If Death Has Taken Something From You, Give It Back: Carl's Book", from 2017, about the grief over her young son's tragic death.
Michael Strunge, who lived from 1958 to 86, got many young readers in the 1980s for his poems about dreams, depression, love, rebellion and city life.
His main work is Verdenssøn, "Son of the World", from 1985.
One of Michael Strunge's later readers was Yahya Hassan, who lived from 1995 to 2020, was a poet, a digter, and made his debut with the poetry collection Yahya Hassan in 2013.
The collection sold in a record print run of far over 100,000 copies, and is the best-selling poetry collection in Denmark ever.
Hassan's poems about growing up and youth life as an immigrant in a ghetto neighbourhood created a violent debate, because they pointed to serious social problems and to clashes between Danish norms and the norms in socially burdened immigrant environments.
One of today's striking Danish authors is Helle Helle, born 1965.
Her toned-down descriptions of everyday life in Denmark's smaller towns mix humour, seriousness, sorrow and joy.
With the novel Rødby-Puttgarden from 2005, she broke through to a bigger audience.
Rødby-Puttgarden depicts the young sisters Jane and Tine's everyday life in Rødbyhavn on Lolland, where they both work as shop assistants on the ferry to Puttgarden.
In recent years Helle Helle has published the novels about Hafni.
In the novel Hafni fortæller, "Hafni Tells", from 2023, a woman goes out on a carefully planned journey through Denmark to celebrate her divorce.
She eats lots of open sandwiches and meets the people of the provinces.
But everything goes wrong, and the journey, which was only supposed to last eight days, ends up taking a month, because Hafni wants to change herself, but does not know how.
Some years later, in the novel Hey Hafni from 2025, we meet Hafni again, where she has travelled to the town of Brighton on England's south coast to find happiness again, which also turns out not to be so simple.
A popular genre in contemporary literature is so-called auto-fiction, where the author describes experiences from their own life and mixes them with fictional elements.
Among the themes are growing up in smaller communities, growing up in a dysfunctional family, and not "belonging", when you are caught between prejudice and traditional norms on the one side and the wish to live out your own ambitions and feelings on the other.
Leonora Christina Skov, born 1976, wrote Den, der lever stille, "The One Who Lives Quietly", in 2017.
It is about the author's upbringing on the narrow path of virtue, "to live quietly", and about the wish to win love and recognition from parents who can almost always find and magnify problems in what she does.
When she has to admit that she is lesbian, she is faced with the choice between living out her feelings on the one hand and losing her parents' acceptance on the other.
Thomas Korsgaard, born 1995, and Glenn Bech, born 1991, both likewise write from experiences of being in a family and in an environment where it is not appreciated to stand out.
Furthermore their memoirs take their starting point in a childhood and youth in families with social and psychological problems.
In the novel trilogy Hvis der skulle komme et menneske forbi, from 2017, En dag vil vi grine af det, from 2018, and Man skulle nok have været der, from 2021, Thomas Korsgaard tells, with both seriousness and irony, about the upbringing he experienced, with lack of money, education, love, and with physical and psychological violence as part of the upbringing.
Glenn Bech's debut book Farskibet, from 2021, describes the trauma his father's suicide has given him.
At the centre of the book is a family that is ruined by what Glenn Bech calls "toxic masculinity".
That is, a view of being a man that involves dominating, intolerant and violent behaviour.
A masculinity that was impossible for the father to live in, difficult for himself to be homosexual in, and which also shows itself through the mother's violent boyfriends.
Glenn Bech is not only a critic of norms about gender and sexuality but also of the city's elites, who are accused of lacking knowledge of the provinces and of the many less privileged population groups in society.
This criticism is expressed not least in his political pamphlet Jeg anerkender ikke længere jeres autoritet, "I No Longer Recognise Your Authority", from 2022.
Suzanne Brøgger, born 1944, and Naja Marie Aidt, born 1963, are both authors, forfattere.
Yahya Hassan was a digter, a poet.
Here is your recap for Episode Three.
Suzanne Brøgger, born 1944, wrote about women's liberation.
Inger Christensen, 1935 to 2009, wrote "Sommerfugledalen" in 1991 and was a Nobel Prize candidate.
Naja Marie Aidt, born 1963, wrote Carls bog in 2017.
Michael Strunge, 1958 to 86, wrote Verdenssøn in 1985.
Yahya Hassan, 1995 to 2020, debuted in 2013, with the best-selling poetry collection in Denmark ever, over 100,000 copies.
Helle Helle, born 1965, wrote Rødby-Puttgarden in 2005, and the Hafni novels in 2023 and 2025.
Auto-fiction mixes real experiences with fiction.
Leonora Christina Skov wrote Den, der lever stille in 2017.
Thomas Korsgaard, born 1995, and Glenn Bech, born 1991, write about growing up in difficult families; Bech wrote Farskibet in 2021.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What are Suzanne Brøgger and Naja Marie Aidt especially known for?
Option A: They are actresses.
Option B: They are painters.
Option C: They are authors.
[DA] Hvad er Suzanne Brøgger og Naja Marie Aidt især kendte for?  A: De er skuespillere  |  B: De er malere  |  C: De er forfattere
The answer is C: They are authors.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: De er forfattere
Question 2.
What is Inger Christensen, 1935 to 2009, especially known for?
Option A: She was a painter.
Option B: She was a poet.
Option C: She was an actress.
[DA] Hvad er Inger Christensen (1935-2009) særlig kendt for?  A: Hun var kunstmaler  |  B: Hun var digter  |  C: Hun var skuespiller
The answer is B: She was a poet.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Hun var digter
Question 3.
What is Yahya Hassan, 1995 to 2020, especially known for?
Option A: He was a musician.
Option B: He was a poet.
Option C: He was a football player.
[DA] Hvad er Yahya Hassan (1995-2020) særligt kendt for?  A: Han var musiker  |  B: Han var digter  |  C: Han var fodboldspiller
The answer is B: He was a poet.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Han var digter
That's the end of this part.
Well done.